you turn it into an act and it's one of
my favorite specials of yours on on uh
netflix thanks but it was your real life
is nobody knows more about
somebody who hamsters so much about him
that's not a joke no he i'm impressed
it's a laugh of him uh being impressed
too
how did you get into the hamster
business um well i didn't necessarily it
wasn't a business of mine but it was
something i came into
they had a guy near us well first of all
they had a man who uh
sold hamsters they had another man who
did tattoo work in the area and at one
point they
would tattoo these hamsters or gerbils
or
gerbils isn't it gerbils
i think
gerbil's friend if it's french we were
doing it by the
roman catholic version
okay so
yeah they would put a tattoo they would
they would de-hair them put a tat put a
branding on the side of them and we used
to sell them outside of concerts outside
of ac dc oh wait you were brand new i
don't like i didn't random no but you
they shaved them and then
what was that what did the tattoo say or
they would dip them in something that
would de-hair them like a d hair and
sauce
oh my gosh
that's horrible
is it horrible
is it horrible it's a beautiful animal
no without the hair with a
what colors did they make them
uh the tattoos were based i remember one
being kind of like an off green and i
remember one being just kind of a black
or purple and what does it say on that
it would say ac dc you know or oh that
was the merch for the merch oh yeah it
was something you would sell so it was
acdc or gl gerald levert we sold them
outside of joe laver we sold ac dc
instead of a t-shirt people where you're
from would buy a
a concert gerber oh you said people on
ecstasy people leaving on drugs maybe
hit him with that freaking ham son
that's money dude you telling me on
drugs you won't buy a hamster i would
thank you okay so and then these are big
fans hey you're a big ac dc fan if they
played two years later did people show
up with the old hamster from the other
they're like the grandparents of the
animal kingdom maybe they're not really
you know we're gonna get a call from
peta they're you don't do it you don't
they don't live long no look this was
the first thing man i got caught into it
it wasn't anything i i
were in the hamster trade well there was
a man near us that bred hamsters
and himself or he used other hamsters oh
i'm sure he's so this is like hamster
trafficking he's in the hamster
trafficking world no yeah you can't [ __ ]
hampshire no i mean i can't even i
i can't fathom how you could i can't
even if you hold the hamster by its tail
his eyes will fall out really yeah
yeah we didn't do any of that we just
kind of fed them and took care of them
you know and vendom
you're an entrepreneur but i wasn't i
was a employee but you said there was a
truck and there was a truck you'd fill
you'd be fill a truck with hamsters oh
dude we filled probably one time i think
we were going uh i want to say it was 3
11
or something it could have been
modest mouse or something one of those
bands we were driving across the lake we
probably had about
70 hamsters in the back of a truck wow
back there just water bottle in them
that they put them in water bottles no
we would uh
uh just feeding them feed them oh you
feel you you gotta keep hydrated because
the wind is ripping through that truck
bed you thought you put them in one wait
you bottle fed uh tattooed naked
hamsters they're not naked well you said
they were hairless hairless yeah they're
hairless man but you dipped them in
something the hair would fall out they'd
be tattooed they'd fill them in a truck
and then you bottle-fed them i didn't
dip them i would bottle feed them yeah
you guys are making it sound sick man
you're right i'm not me not me i'm
thinking
how much does a tattooed ac dc hamster
go for at the time three dollars
it wasn't the band that it's not the
official band merch right like they
didn't do they get a cut of it yourself
oh it wasn't sanctioned or anything like
that no this was uh before i think a lot
of the
uh
naming rights and all that was a big
deal licensing licensing was there a
hamster stand
no no no it was straight out of the
truck wow
so you'd bottle feed them and how would
one choose one hamster over another like
well the most of the hamsters now the uh
i think people mostly just like it on
size but mostly it is a lot of people
honestly are on drugs and you hit them
with that hand yeah you put it in their
hand and they can't stand too they can't
say no you can't say anything enough the
other story i have um
fur baby in your hand baby you get that
little freaking get one of the little
frederick douglass in your hand baby you
[ __ ] they got that big beard what are
the profit margins on something like
that huh what are your profit margins
man i'm telling you guys y'all keep
acting like i was in the upper echelons
of it man
i was a child i was a employee dude i
was telling i don't even think i was how
did you get this game how did you get
that how did you get that job like why
did they they said theo vaughn we need
people to sell how did they find you or
how did you find them my friend bert did
it okay
and he was trying he trustworthy guy he
is what he's working on god but he's
okay burt's dead
bert's dead okay oh sorry i think he's
dead actually i uh
i'm honestly not even sure because there
was a vague fake facebook post about him
but what it is it was in a horrible
hamstring he said r.i.p but it was right
around halloween i remember
so that's sometimes i think i i should
have followed up on it but maybe it was
our ep bert like he wanted to be rep oh
like he wanted to be rep like he wanted
to be
like a republican
it could have been his grandmother used
to be his grandmother was named ethel
right and she used to be our babysitter
okay
that's a sweet story
[Music]